police in france have arrested a third
suspect in connection with a deadly
terror attack in nice
authorities say a suspected terrorist
stabbed and killed three people
inside a catholic church on thursday the
attack comes just two weeks after a
teacher was beheaded
in a paris suburb france has raised its
security alert to its highest level
president emmanuel macron called the
attacks islamist acts of terror
his remarks have led to tens of tens of
thousands of muslims to protest in the
middle east
mts tayab is in paris and joins us mts
good morning
well good morning the streets of paris
are eerily empty as france enters the
second day
of a strict covid 19 lockdown and as
many come to terms with yet
another brutal attack
across france church bells ring in honor
of those who were killed
and as mourners continue to pay their
respects new details are emerging
about the attacker investigators say his
name is ibrahim asawi
a 21-year-old tunisian national who
entered europe just over a month ago
and is now in critical condition after
being shot by police
his mother who lives in tunisia says he
called her just days ago to tell her she
was in france
saying only that she should pray for him
since last month there's been three
separate assaults connected to cartoons
depicting the prophet muhammad that were
first published in 2015
by the satirical magazine charlie hebdo
and were republished again
this september the images
seen as a gratuitous insult to islam
have sparked protests across several
muslim nations
much of the fury is pointed directly at
president macron
whose defense of the crude caricatures
as part of france's secular values
has opened him up to accusations of
deliberately stoking
anti-muslim sentiment for political gain
a strategy that may have backfired
internationally
but seems to be winning influence at
home despite the staggering cost
now president macron has more than
doubled the number of troops on the
streets to over 7
thousand with many here fearing more
violence
michelle mts tayyip in paris
thank you